der neue klimaschutzminister robert
habeck stellt hier in berlin seine
eröffnungsbilanz vor sie zeigt wie sehr
deutschland in sachen klimaschutz hinter
den erwartungen liegt die klimaziele
werden in diesem jahr aller voraussicht
nach verfehlen
mit einem umfangreichen maßnahmenpaket
nachbessern wie genau das aussehen soll
erfahren wir in wenigen momenten live
hierbei bild wir schauen mal auf das
live signal aus der
bundespressekonferenz meine damen und
herren da sehen wir es schon und wir
gehen direkt hinein
zu robert habeck der seine pläne
vorstellen
[Musik]
und vielleicht letztmalig ein frohes
neues jahr ein jahr das hoffentlich gute
gesundheit erhalten bleibt dem land ist
ermöglicht durch die verschiedenen
krisen die wir haben gut durchzukommen
und
[Musik]
auf konzentrierte und gute
zusammenarbeit wir haben uns hier
eingeladen über einladen lassen von der
bundespressekonferenz um einmal mit
einem schulterblick zu starten wo wir im
bereich klimaschutz und energiepolitik
stehen um vielleicht in dieser
legislatur aus meiner sicht letztmalig
zurückzuschauen und dann den blick
beginnend mit diesem tag dieser woche
komplett und konsequent nach vorne zu
richten
aber einmal müssen wir den
startpunkt noch definieren und schauen
wo wir stehen und das wird jetzt nicht
so sehr überraschen nach der
vorberichterstattung der letzten tage
wir starten nicht auf der ziellinie
sondern mit einem gehörigen rückstand
wir müssen jetzt in den nächsten
jahren effizienter und schneller werden
das tempo und die konsequenz müssen zu
nehmen im prinzip kann man über den
groben daumen sagen wir müssen dreimal
besser seien in allen bereichen und ich
gehe gleich nochmal ausgeschiedenen
verschiedenen sektoren und sparten ein
wenn wir mit den co2 emissionen die ja
die grundlage alles tun sind beginnen so
sehen wir dass die
sondereffekte des jahres 20 die es
ermöglicht haben im jahr 2020 die
zielmarke von minus 40 prozent co2
emissionen einzuhalten im jahr 21 nicht
gewirkt haben und weg sind das heißt
strukturell sind wir deutlich schlechter
als die geplanten und vorher und
vorgegebenen ziele wir werden einen
anstieg der emission um vier prozent
wahrscheinlich haben davon gehen die
prognosen aus oder von 25 millionen
tonnen dh im jahr 21 werden wir die
emissionssenkung minus 40 prozent
deutlich verfehlen
wenn wir den pfad der bisherigen
maßnahmen fortschreiben werden wir
2030 die zielverfehlung noch deutlicher
sehen wir werden dann 15 prozent unter
den vorher irgendwelche unter dem
minderungszielen seien also nicht - 65
prozent co2 emissionen sondern ungefähr
minus 50 prozent co2 emissionen das ist
dann in zahlen ausgedrückt 200 millionen
tonnen zu viel und weil wir dann noch
ein budget von 400 millionen tonnen
eigentlich haben ist es 50 prozent der
menge die wir haben darüber ich habe das
einmal mitgemacht und einer grafik dass
man das sehen kann nicht von hinten
nicht aber dass er übertragen wird kann
man es sich hier vielleicht ein bisschen
sich daran zoom wir sehen wir das jahr
2020 das ist die korona krise der
deutliche absenkung des balkens habe ich
es eben nicht politisch induzierten oder
politisch getrieben und dann noch in der
prognose die zahlen doch nicht wirklich
fort aber dann sehen sie das hier ja 21
dabei wieder nach oben geht da sind wir
also und da müssen wir hin und aber das
jetzt groß sieht sieht man dass man die
minderung sagen ja mal hier wird im
groben daumen hier sind wir gestartet
der letzten
1990 also zwei balken sind wir unter
vier müssen wir runter gehen in deutlich
kürzerer zeit und den schwarzen
verlaufen sie hier sehen das sind die
minderung ergebnisse der bisher
beschlossenen politischen maßnahmen und
wenn wir alles umsetzen das im moment
politisch vereinbart ist landen wir hier
und hier müssen wir sein und hierhin zu
kommen sie sehen also dass die aufgabe
großes
gigantisch ist
wir haben in zahlen im jahr 2010 bis 20
die emission in deutschland um 15
millionen tonnen senken können wir
müssen dann jährlich im durchschnitt
müssen sie
2022 bis 30 um über 40 millionen tonnen
senken das ist die der faktor drei von
dem ich gesprochen habe jetzt schon bei
den
emissionssenkungen wir haben es
geschafft in deutschland in den letzten
30 jahren
erneuerbaren energien zu einem anteil
von 42 prozent der stromversorgung zu
bringen das ist eine leistung die man
anerkennen muss diejenigen die debatte
länger verfolgt haben können sich daran
erinnern dass zu beginn des ausbaus der
erneuerbaren gewarnt wurde das mehr als
34 5 prozent anteil der erneuerbaren das
stromsystem überhaupt nicht verkraften
könnte nun sind wir 30 jahre später bei
über 40 prozent
aber wir haben dafür 30 jahre gebraucht
und wir haben noch acht jahre zeit den
anteil nach plan der bundesregierung
nach koalitionsvertrag auf 80 prozent zu
bringen also 30 jahre gut 40 prozent
acht jahre um dann das doppelte noch mal
zu machen dabei sind bisher in den
berechnungen die steigenden strombedarf
nicht eingepreist worden deutschland
verbraucht ungefähr 500 60
terawattstunden strom pro jahr das wird
aber steigen durch rollout der
wärmepumpen durch hochlauf der
e-mobilität wir werden dann ungefähr bei
7 100 terawattstunden jährlich liegen
die schätzungen reichen von 680 bis 750
also die 80 prozent bezogen auf den
strombedarf ist eben noch mal bezogen
auf eine größere menge was die aufgabe
nur noch größer macht bedrückend ist
dass der trend in die falsche richtung
geht wir haben über die letzten drei
jahre ein zubau von offshore-wind das
ist würde ich sagen noch einmal der
lastesel der erneuerbaren energien von
einem gigawatt gehabt für zu wenig
offshore ist nahezu komplett zum
erliegen gekommen
man sieht es hier beim anteil der ich
habe es noch mal mitgebracht beim anteil
der erneuerbaren am bruttostromverbrauch
das ist da wo wir sind sie sehen sogar
dass wir im letzten jahr ein zurückgehen
haben das wird man auch hinten erkennen
können hier geht es immer nicht steil
genug immer unbedingt aber es geht immer
bergauf die sonne einmal geht's bergab
in einem jahr wo wir eigentlich die
kehrtwende nun wirklich einleiten müssen
haben wir den anteil am
bruttostromverbrauch
eine bayern heuer waren noch geringer
und sie sehen wie schnell die kurve dann
nach oben gehen muss das ist der faktor
drei von dem ich gesprochen habe
hier sehen sie dann noch einmal in den
grafiken das was ich gesagt habe den
zubau von wind und photovoltaik das ist
der super von wind das dunkelblaue ist
offshore hier wurde auch schon okay zu
gebaut würde ich seinen ging es runter
und die letzten jahre wurde überhaupt
nicht mehr auch schon zugebaut und schon
ging es ganz gut los und das sind die
letzten jahre gewesen hier sind wir das
ist klose dessen was wir erreichen
müssen in den nächsten jahren also sehen
sie sich die zahlen an das sind die
jahre des maximalen zubaus gewesen als
es richtig gut ging und sehen sie sich
an was wir erreichen müssen bei
photovoltaik ist die tendenz ein
bisschen besser sie sehen dass es bei
niedrigen jahren hier dann leicht
aufwärts gegangen ist aber gemessen an
dem was wir machen müssen ist selbst das
okay zu bauen würde ich sagen nur die
startrampe hier müssen wir hin und das
kulminiert ist dann der zubau der
erneuerbaren energien über die nächsten
jahre die wir leisten müssen
um den strombedarf und den anteil den
wir dafür haben decken zu können
wenn wir uns anschauen woran es hapert
dann sind die gründe vielfältig vor
allem ist bei oft bei onshore
festzustellen dass die fläche einfach
schlichtweg nicht da ist um diese mengen
zu bauen brauchen wir zwei prozent der
bundesdeutschen fläche gute nachricht
ist 98 prozent der fläche sind
freizuhalten und werden auch nicht
gebraucht
ausgewiesen theoretisch sind 0,8 prozent
faktisch zur verfügung stehen 0,5 oder
das was sie erleben ist ein viertel
dessen was wir kennen ein viertel dessen
was wir tatsächlich brauchen einige
flächen sind natürlich mit alten anlagen
bestellt das sind auch häufig die sehr
windstarken flächen das heißt über das
repowering schonen wir die fläche und
haben trotzdem einen guten zubau von
leistung aber wir brauchen mehr fläche
völlig klar ich verzichte jetzt heute
hier darauf die länder einzeln
durchzugehen bin aber mit den
landesregierungen
kontakt und suche den kontakt und werde
auch persönlich besuchen um das dann
einzeln durch zu sprechen aber es gibt
nur zwei länder die in die nähe des 2
prozent ziels kommen das sind hessen und
schleswig-holstein alle anderen ligen
darunter und dann muss man jetzt nicht
lange um den heißen brei herum liegen da
werden einige gespräche zu führen sein
und das wird ein mühsamer prozess werden
allerdings auf die mühsam kalt des
prozesses nicht zu einer zeitlichen
verzögerung führen wir müssen die
flächen schaffen sonst kommen wir da
nicht dran und alle müssen mithelfen
dass wir diese flächen schaffen wenn man
sich anschaut was weiterhin passieren
soll wenn man in die verschiedenen
sektoren reingeht wir reden ja beim
klimaschutz jetzt nicht mehr alleine vom
strommarkt also dem ausbau von
photovoltaik und wind sondern auch über
industrie über mobilität über wärme so
ein paar zahlen und zu verdeutlichen was
ansteht alleine für den jährlichen
verbrauch der stahlindustrie wenn sie
auf grün stahl umstellt werden 15
terawattstunden wasserstoff 2030
benötigt 3 terawattstunden wasserstoff
sind bisher bundesweit für alle sektoren
in der planung grund geplant als wir
brauchen einen massiven hochlauf von
wasserstoff wir wollen ein rollout der
wärmepumpen also strom getrieben die
dann aber dafür sorgen dass die
wärmeversorgung erneuerbar ist auf vier
bis sechs millionen das ist eine für 4
bis versechsfachung der bisherigen
zahlen und planungen
wir haben beschlossen und das ist schon
ja auch berichtet worden den hochlauf
der e mobilität auf 15 millionen
fahrzeuge
2030 das bedeutet dann aber auch in der
konsequenz dass wir jährlich 100.000
neue ladepunkte brauchen eine große
infrastruktur aufgabe die da auf uns
zukommt
das alles zusammen nehmen steht das land
vor einer großen politischen debatte
hier in der bundespressekonferenz kann
man die zahlen referieren und die
grafiken hochhalten und ihre kameras
klicken und man sagt okay ganz schön
sportliche aufgabe das wird mal
interessant werden wie das anzugehen ist
wenn man dann im land unterwegs ist weiß
man dass mit diesen zahlen nicht nur
eine technische debatte verknüpft ist
sondern eine soziale debatte eine
debatte die die kulturelle identität von
räumen betrifft der zubau von
erneuerbaren energien macht etwas mit
dem ländlichen raum eine debatte die das
verhältnis von staat als großen
verbrauchszentren oder industriezentren
und ländlichen raum neu betrifft eine
debatte die ost west nord süd in den
verschiedenen kompetenzen und auch
debatten lagen und politischen
mehrheiten betrifft also man muss sich
keine illusionen darüber machen dass das
leben nicht nur eine technische frage
ist sondern auch eine frage ist die tief
in die gesellschaftliche wirklichkeit
eingreift und nur dann gewonnen werden
kann wenn sie auch als gesellschaftliche
debatte geführt werden wird sich
jedenfalls werde versuchen das so
aufzusetzen
um das ganze in gang zu bringen haben
wir uns ein ehrgeiziges arbeitsprogramm
gesetzt wir planen zwei große artikel
gesetzespakete dass eine an eine art
oster paket im frühjahr
soll die sofort wirksamen maßnahmen
bündeln dann im frühjahr um ostern herum
durch kabinett so dass dann die
parlamentarischen befassung bis zur
sommerpause abgeschlossen sind einiges
von denen wird dann beihilfe flüchtig
sein muss in europa genehmigt werden
aber das was prioritäre wirksamkeit
entfaltet muss alles hin
2022 erledigt sein damit es in 23
wirksam wird ich gehe gleich noch mal
ein bisschen durch nun planen wir einen
sommer paket wurde an die weiteren
prioritären maßnahmen die dann wirksam
werden und die flächen die
fördermöglichkeiten die neuen
gesetzlichen normen
erstellen dann in der zweiten
jahreshälfte ebenfalls durch das
parlamentarische verfahren bringen also
oster und sommer paket sind begriffe für
die kabinettsbefassung die dann in den
verfahren die nachgelagert sind
parlamentarische befassung im bundestag
gegebenenfalls in den landesparlamenten
im bundesrat oder notifizierung in der
eu noch in 22 möglich machen
ein paar bereiche kann man
identifizieren die jetzt sofort
angegangen werden müssen quasi mit
diesem schulterblick des heutigen tages
zurück dann blick nach vorne das ist die
neue aufstellung des eeg noch dann ihren
oster paket mit der erhöhung der
ausschreibung entsprechend des 80
prozent ziels wie eben in der grafik
vorgestellt mit der definition der
überragenden öffentlichen bedeutung der
erneuerbaren energien das ist ja das was
im koalitionsvertrag noch mal
festgeschrieben wurde was sich aber
logisch ergibt wenn wir die erneuerbaren
energien zum rückgrat der
energieversorgung machen dann sind sie
sicherheitsrelevant und müssen auch so
behandelt werden auch in der schutz
güterabwägung gegenüber anderen
schutzgüter und der abschaffung der eeg
umlage wir werden zweitens ein solar
beschleunigungs paket auf den weg
bringen so dass dinge wie großzügigere
nutzung von mieter strom aber auch die
solarpflicht neue flächen für
freiflächen pv und bessere fördersätze
dort vereinbart werden so dass wir zu
einem rollout der pv der solaranlagen in
deutschland noch einmal kommen werden
wir werden drittens dann die maßnahmen
ergreifen die genehmigte schlecht für
windkraftanlagen hoffentlich schneller
zu einer bebauung führen können wir
haben in deutschland in der summe acht
bis neun gigawatt peak kann man sich
merken essen grunde ein
atomkraftwerk in der kapazität
genehmigten flächen da könnt ihr also
gebaut werden die aber aufgrund von
anderen shootern oder gütern belegt sind
das sind vor allem radaranlagen des
deutschen wetterdienstes oder der
deutschen flugsicherung für analoge dre
funkfeuer also eine sehr alte technik
die als backup vorgehalten wird und
flächen wo die bundeswehr sagt da kann
nicht gebaut werden aus
sicherheitsüberlegungen
die haben natürlich alle in sich ihre
mehr oder weniger starke berechtigung
aber wir müssen da vorankommen und ich
bin mit den kollegen in guten gespräch
und hoffe dass wir kurzfristig dort
flächen frei räumen können so dass der
ausbau dann wieder mindestens auf den
genehmigten flächen in gang kommt da
sind wir noch gar nicht mehr artenschutz
und naturschutz versteckten verfahren
das sind einfach nur flächen die
eigentlich zur verfügung stehen wo es
eine konkurrenz abwägung oder eine
güterabwägung gibt die noch mal neue
vorzunehmen sein wird dann das
winterland gesetzt das wird sicherlich
eine kompliziertere operation das ist
das was sich hinter dem zwei prozent
ziel verbirgt wir wollen mit dem oster
paket die sogenannten kontrakt kabeln
kontakt defenses verträge das sind die
förderverträge für die industrie auf den
weg bringen im grunde der logik nach
wenn jetzt die industrie sich auf den
weg macht mit den verschiedenen sparten
beispielsweise weil wasserstoff
einzusetzen und die höhere kosten hat
gibt es einen vertrag mit der
öffentlichen hand diese mehrkosten zu
erstatten wenn aber beispielsweise durch
einen höheren co2 preis die neue technik
sich rechnet also die produktion auf
einmal günstiger wird zahlt wird ein
stück jedenfalls der fördermaßnahmen
zurückgezahlt all das soll programmiert
werden das löst dann die bremse bei den
investitionen der industrie das saftige
sicherheit für die investition und wird
zu den entsprechenden umbaumaßnahmen in
der industrie führen wir werden die
wärme strategie auflegen die vor allem
über die kommunale wärme planung
dann dafür zu führen soll dass wir ab
2025 65 prozent erneuerbare energie für
alle neue heizanlagen haben werden dazu
gehören auch fördermaßnahmen für die
fernwärmenetze also da wo es
verbundsysteme geht kann man ja
gebündelt energien führen wir setzen vor
allem darauf dass ein förderprogramm das
gerade in der notifizierung bei der eu
liegt das baby das bundesprogramm für
effiziente wärmenetze einen großen
effekt hat sodass wir auch
beispielsweise industrielle abwärme
stärker in die fernwärmenetze rein
nehmen werden und den rollout der
gekommen habe ich schon gesprochen noch
drei punkte gebäude energie gesetz neu
aufzusetzen also die effizienz kriterien
für bauen und sanieren hochzusetzen
gleichzeitig die förderung anzupassen
und sowohl die sanierung wie auch die
versorgung mit erneuerbaren energien neu
abzuwägen ist teil der pakete die
wasserstoff strategie muss neu aufgelegt
werden in den drei bestandteilen
förderung
infrastruktur und beschaffung von
wasserstoff beschaffung heißt sowohl
importe von wasserstoff die vereinbaren
zu verändern sind wir aber auch
standorte für elektrolyseur zu
identifizieren also da wo große mengen
erneuerbarer strom in deutschland führt
über sind das sind ideale standorte um
dann noch einmal wasserstoff in
deutschland in erneuerbare energien in
deutschland in wasserstoff umzuwandeln
und
all das zusammen macht diese genannten
oster und sommer pakete aus insgesamt
mit dem blick zurück über die schulter
wo wir stehen und den abfallenden kurven
der blick nach vorne es ist eine große
politische aufgabe aber eine die
natürlich auch für das land eine enorme
chance bereithält und für die politische
kultur eine enorme chance bereithält
wenn wir sie bestehen diese aufgabe wenn
wir das angehen werden wir darüber zu
einem neuen verhältnis von bund und land
kommen also die föderale das föderale
zusammenspiel besser machen können wir
werden unsere industrie erneuern und die
industrie erneuern heißt eben auch
wertschöpfung arbeitsplätze
wohlstand für mittelstand und handwerk
bereitstellen zu können wir werden
wieder
innovationsland sein und wir werden
bürokratie und planungsprozesse
schlanker machen müssen und können
dadurch wir werden also lernen wie wir
besser werden und was gibt es für eine
bessere aufgabe politisch zu
verantworten zu lernen wie man besser
werden kann ich jedenfalls und das haus
bei dem ich mich herzlich bedanken das
ist in sehr kurzer zeit diesen soliden
berichte ich ihnen jetzt ja vor dreißig
seiten ungefähr was ich hier in dürren
worten vorgestellt habe tja lernen wie
man besser werden kann was kann es
besseres geben jan schäfer bei uns im
studio die erste bilanz von robert
habeck dem klimaschutz und
wirtschaftsminister den eindruck also
das programm was robert habeck jetzt
noch mal deutlicher skizziert hat ist
wirklich wahnsinnig ambitioniert er hat
ja am anfang seiner pressekonferenz
erklärt wo deutschland derzeit steht
beispielsweise beim thema erneuerbare
energien hat gesagt dass im abgelaufenen
jahr rund 42 prozent des stromes aus
erneuerbaren energien stammt also in
einer von 30 jahren ein anteil von 42
prozent und dann hat er gesagt dieser
anteil der muss als verdoppelt werden
mehr als verdoppelt eigentlich war auch
der energiehunger weiter steigen wird
von deutschland verdoppelt werden und
zwar innerhalb von acht jahren und das
ist sicherlich eine herausforderung bei
der ich sagen würde das kann ich mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen dass das
klappen kann denn das bedeutet unter
anderem dass und das hat robert habeck
auch ausgeführt in diesem land
wahnsinnig viele zum beispiel neue
windräder aufgestellt werden müssen wir
wissen dass es mit dem aufstellen von
windrädern nicht ganz so einfach ist
auch die zahl aus den letzten jahren
zeigen dass es eher ein weniger großen
zuwachs an wen haltet verdeutliche dem
er gesagt hat das was wir jetzt haben
sind 0,5 prozent der fläche zwei prozent
müssen wir aber haben man kann sich also
vorstellen wie viele wind masten da
zusätzlich dazu kommen nicht genau da
geht das problemlos denn wir wissen auch
so ein windrad das dann am ende oder die
windräder die zwei prozent der fläche in
deutschland dann besiegeln sollen das
ist ja nicht ohne probleme auch vor ort
umzusetzen also er hat gesagt kein
bundesland konnte annähernd überhaupt
bisher an werden überhaupt
schleswig-holstein hessen in die nähe
aber da wird er natürlich große probleme
haben mit seiner eigenen klientel zum
teil nämlich auch umweltschützer die
sagen nein also wir reden doch jetzt
hier nicht bitte für neue windräder es
gibt ein beispiel aus dem hessischen
reinhardswald beispielsweise da sollen
neue windräder aufgestellt werden schon
seit einigen jahren es gibt massiven
protest auch von umweltschützern sagen
ja wir können doch nicht einen alten
wald roden für windkraft also das ist
hoch ambitioniert da wird robert habeck
sich ganz schön strecken müssen und ein
bisschen ist mir am ende auch
aufgefallen es wird wieder versucht
diese ganze energie wende als den großen
jobmotor zu verkaufen hat auch gesagt
wir werden wieder innovationsland sagen
ja ich wo hat denn robert habeck die
letzten jahre gelebt also deutschland
ist ein
innovationsland ohne frage aber das ist
das was die grünen natürlich immer
versuchen zu sagen die energiewende die
ein neuer innovationstreiber ist und
damit staatlich verordnet werden kann
david robert habeck falsch jobs kündigt
staatlich verordnet werden jobs
entstehen und die ganze energiewende hat
ja auch für die industrie hohe hohe
implikation ist alles muss finanziert
werden und was bis jetzt auch hier
fehlte war ein preisschild was kostet
das was gibt es dann für subventionen
für unternehmen wie werden jobs
künstlich am leben gehalten oder
gefördert und am ende die frage ja wie
wir das alles bezahlt beispielsweise
über steuererhöhungen das ist zum
beispiel eine frage unbeantwortet habe
katja förderung angesprochen gerade für
industrie hat vor dem oster paket
gesprochen und auch von einem sommer
paket was auf den weg gebracht werden
soll aber das problem natürlich mit den
fehlenden flächen ist damit natürlich
nicht gelöst ist nicht gelöst sein er
debatte ist jetzt beispielsweise auch
eine solardach pflicht zumindest für neu
gebaute
gewerbebetriebe da heißt es aus dem
handwerk das ist alles schön und gut
aber wir haben gar nicht genug
mitarbeiter zurzeit also fehlen im
handwerk ja viele viele
mitarbeiter viele stellen sind offen
also um auch sowas umzusetzen können bis
20.30 also wir haben zum einen dass
flächen problem wir haben dann ein
kapazitätsproblem was diejenigen angeht
die sowas installieren soll also da gibt
es viele dinge und am ende natürlich das
kostenproblem er hat das auch seinen
schaubildern ganz gut dargestellt erst
dachte ich willkommen im digitalen
zeitalter aber am ende konnte man
tatsächlich gut sehen welcher
herausforderung da tatsächlich noch sind
was in wenigen jahren erreicht werden
muss jan schäfer vielen dank für die
einordnung zu diesen
großen herausforderungen die uns da
bevorsteht